avec matteo ghisalberti rédacteur en
chef de putsch médias bonjour à vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors l'italie poursuit son
déconfinement les bars et les
restaurants les commerces rouvrent à
partir d'aujourd'hui
quels sont les échos que vous avez sans
doute il ya une nouvelle dynamique qui
s'est mise en place
la naissance que on a vu que les
personnes ont recommencé leurs activités
presque normalement
il y avait beaucoup de personnes qui qui
attendait avec impatience la possibilité
de recommencer au moins a pas bougé
entre les différentes communes entre les
différences et régions et puis
naturellement ils avaient toutes les
petites activités économiques et aussi
les gangs qui attendaient avec
impatience de pouvoir recommencer à
travailler à créer de la richesse
après de ressources pour le pays et pour
les communautés locales
on imagine aussi que le moral et
commença à leur devenir meilleur parce
qu'on voit que l'épidémie recule en
europe en italie on a donné les chiffres
il ya quelques instants
oui effectivement il ya aussi ma poussée
de du moral des du sentiment des gens
qui sont plus confiantes mais les gens
aussi ont compris que ils doivent à
compter sur une voie compter sur leurs
forces dans le sens que les italiens les
citoyens italiens ont bien présente
désormais que l'europe ne bougera pas
pour eux ni pour d'autres pays qui ont
été durement touchés par la crise
deco vide enfin la part d'amis donc ils
sont prêtes à recommencer à travailler
et je pense que les prochains mois
seront ceux où on verra des prises de
positions importantes de la part de
plusieurs instances à l'intérieur de
l'italie peut-être pas le gouvernement
parce que il est fortement soutenu par
la commission européenne actuelle mais
on a vu déjà des régions qui ont demandé
l d'avoir la possibilité de gérer
différemment la relance la
reconstruction parce que l'italie a été
frappé comme si elle était touchée par
une guerre et donc on verra peut-être de
dynamique nouvelle plus eurosceptiques
par rapport à ce qu'on a l'habitude de
voir en italie
et justement quel rôle les délits
peuvent jouer dans les négociations
actuelles au niveau européen pour une
relance économique on l'a dit tout à
l'heure on attend la conférence de
presse dans gala merkel et d'emmanuel
macron pour tenter de redonner du
souffle à l'europe qui avance divisée on
s'en rend compte alors il faut faire une
distinction entre le gouvernement
italien et les citoyens et l'économie
des eau la halle le tissu économique
italien le gouvernement italien restera
aligner très probablement ou aux
indications de bruxelles et donc
renoncera aussi a demandé plus de
soutien aussi du point de vue de la
flexibilité et éventuellement d aide les
citoyens italiens et le tissu économique
veut éviter d'avoir déjà de recevoir un
traitement un peu comme celui qui a reçu
la grèce il y a une dizaine d'années et
surtout ils souhaitent avoir plus de
marge de manoeuvre en ce qui concerne la
possibilité ou pour le pays des gérer
ses comptes et donc d'avoir plus de
marge dans les politiques de bilan pour
aider les entreprises à serrer lancé
donc à embaucher
cd confiné que rapidement et la question
des frontières
l'italie prévoit de réouvrir ses
frontières début juin la salle aura
quelles conséquences selon vous sa doute
c'est une bonne nouvelle
il faut dire aussi que il faudra faire
attention à ce qu'ils aient le
gouvernement italien dira ou ne tirera
pas d'un sens que tu es gouvernement a
réalisé de mauvaises performances en
termes de communication parce que la
communication pendant secret ces trois
derniers mois a été très chaotique et
puis on a découvert que certains
indicateurs
à propos de la du risque de cette panne
demi en réalité étaient déjà dans les
mains d'une partie du gouvernement en
janvier donc il faudra voir devra être
très attentif à la communication du
gouvernement mais il faut aussi dire que
les régions italiennes ont obtenu de
pouvoir garder la main sur tout un tas
des décisions qui seront prises déjà
elles pourront re fermer ou ouvrir
davantage leurs leur territoire et est
donc je pense aussi que il faudra suivre
ce que les régions aux italiennes 10
pour voir si effectivement il ya une
nouvelle vague qui arrive ou en tout cas
des nouveaux foyers qui s'est créée
parce que elles sont plus proches du
haut niveau disons de base des citoyens
et des admis 500 locales et donc ça sera
plus facile à voir leurs points de vue
que par rapport à celui du gouvernement
merci beaucoup matteo ghisalberti je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
de putsch médias merci à vous